تشير التقديرات الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
دمر اكثر من 70% من قطاع غزه خلال الاشهر
الثلاثه الماضيه
بالقصف لكن هل يعقل ان كل ما تم تدميره هو
اهداف عسكريه فعليا ساريكم مقطع فيديو
لجندي اسرائيلي سعيد بتفجير بنايه ضخمه
فقط ليرسل رساله الى المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيل
شاهد ب
منهل
ر
غ طيب ما دخل هذا المبنى بغضب جندي
اسرائيلي من محكمته العليا هل لانها مثلا
الغت قانون الحد من المعقوليه الذي طالما
دافع
عنه نتنياهو لتعديل القانون الاساسي
للسلطه القضائيه ليس سعيدا مثلا بالقر
ولن يحاسبه احد يدمر غزه في الكامل علما
ان احكام القانون الدولي الانساني تقضي
بحضر الاضرار بالممتلكات كوسيله وقائيه
ومنع تدمير الممتلكات لتحقيق الردع حتى في
حالات الضروره العسكريه ساريكم فيديو اخر
لجنود الاحتلال يحتفلون يصفقون بعد تفجير
مربع سكني كامل بكبسه زر في خان
يونس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تفجير المباني الخاليه في غزه بعد اخلائها
وتهجير سكانها نحو الجنوب هل رايتم فيها
خطه ممنهجه ابدا بهذه التغريده من بن احمد
يقول بعد ان اوجعهم المقاومه خاصه في خان
يونس لجاوا كعادتهم الى الانتقام من
الابرياء العزال هذه هي عاداتهم بشير يقول
سيسكن القيام والحفر ولكنهم لن يتركوهم
تنعموا بالامان لن تكون هناك حياه ولا
اقتصاد في اسرائيل شهم قال ياتي يوم
وينتقم منكم من جديد لا تتعجل يموت صاحب
الحق لا الحق الحق لا يموت
فيولد طفل يحمله احمد باسم قال لك انها
خطه شامله لتدمير جميع نازل حتى لا يتمكن
النازحون الذين طلب منهم الذهاب الى رفح
مؤقتا من العوده هذه هي النكبه الثانيه
نفس سيناريو ما حدث في عام 48 وما
بعده هل تمكنت اسرائيل بعد كل هذا الدمار
الذي احدثته من تحقيق اهدافها اهداف الحرب
بعد ثلاثه اشهر من بدئها صحيفه يدعوت
احرونوت قالت ان اهداف الحرب لم تتحقق بعد
وان اسرائيل تواجه صعوبات وت غير مسبوقه
في تاريخها وان هذه الحرب هي الاعلى كلفه
وبلغت نحو 60 مليار دولار